I'm Kurt Anderson a novelist and the
host of Studio 360
first of all there's the problem of
novelists being all that celebrated in
America if they're very serious as
novelist III I'm not Shh well it's an
interesting question
III think I as I write about an
introduction to this to this novel I
think it's I think that the job category
of voice of an generation or voice of a
nation spokesperson and household name
novelist no longer exists subversiveness
is a different issue but I think you
know that probably makes it even harder
I you know I think that to be that to be
extremely well known sell a lot of books
well regarded as a novelist you know all
those things are difficult and
subversiveness in this day and age makes
it even more difficult I suppose I guess
you could say that Norman Mailer on a
certain level for instance was a
subversive novelist but you know I think
the the more the audience for
subversiveness is a niche audience at
this point in America
of the ones I've done a considerable
amount of I would say fiction writing is
the most difficult and for that reason
the most gratifying to to throw myself
into still an attempt to climb that
mountain
although I've written fiction here and
there for many years I've done it you
know essentially quasi full-time for now
13 years so it's still relatively new to
me and therefore I'm still figuring it
out it's also - to create something that
one is entirely in control of oneself is
is more difficult and scary because it's
all the buck stops here always and and -
- in this day and age of short attention
span and small bite entertainment and
media - to try to be interesting enough
to keep people paying attention for many
many hours to your one thing is it's a
high bar and and so it's that you know
the stakes are high for a writer and
reader
I'm fairly disciplined I worked in an
office you know for enough years before
I was working for myself at home that
the the ritual of sitting in a desk and
starting to type was was ingrained in me
so it's pretty much the same with
nonfiction but all this the the
preparatory work of nonfiction the
research the interviewing all that kind
of stuff you know I find I'm able to do
you know at midnight or 3:00 in the
morning in a way that writing fiction
I'm not able to do and in those kind of
off hours
sure right here and there I mean you
know you know I think I think there are
there are still disinterested
fair-minded seekers of of the truth
around that aren't necessarily on fox
news and aren't necessarily on MSNBC but
and you know and not to not to you know
there are also decent people on at in
even in those even in the at the margins
even and the left and on the right so
yeah I'm not I am not without hope but
the the trend of the last dozen years in
this realm you know is a little
worrisome to me
sure right here and there I mean you
know you know I think I think there are
there are still disinterested
fair-minded seekers of of the truth
around that aren't necessarily on fox
news and aren't necessarily on MSNBC but
and you know and not to not to you know
there are also decent people on at in
even in those even in the at the margins
even and the left and on the right so
yeah I'm not I am not without hope but
the the trend of the last dozen years in
this realm you know is a little
worrisome to me
sure right here and there I mean you
know you know I think I think there are
there are still disinterested
fair-minded seekers of of the truth
around that aren't necessarily on fox
news and aren't necessarily on MSNBC but
and you know and not to not to you know
there are also decent people on at in
even in those even in the at the margins
even and the left and on the right so
yeah I'm not I am not without hope but
the the trend of the last dozen years in
this realm you know is a little
worrisome to me
sure thing they don't because they don't
look so easy there are fewer of them
suddenly for one thing and and I think
now for for a whole generation or two of
people to whom Oh job on Wall Street Oh
a job in a bank that looks like an easy
way to make my pile quickly and then get
out and do what I really want to do that
that I think the last year has proven
that that is not such a not such an easy
way to go and that indeed following
one's passions is is ultimately a sure
bet which isn't to say that people still
won't I mean people who actually like
being in finance great they can still do
that but I think I think there were I
know that there have been a lot of
people over the last 20 years or so who
went into those jobs simply because it
seemed and was an easy way to make a lot
of money
well a lot of the best and the brightest
are doing things like Teach for America
and and trying to become teachers I mean
that in terms of metrics that are
available to us you can look at that and
say my god you know one in nine Ivy
League senior signs up for Teach for
America they're turning away you know
several for every spot they have so you
know that that in a more than anecdotal
way is where you can say there's a lot
of best and brightest young people going
there but you know in terms of for this
radio show I do this public radio show I
ds2dio 360 we have again I would say 10
applicants for every intern that we can
take on so you know and we're paying
them barely a dime so I see I see you
know best and brightest people going
into the arts and and and and you know
in my little window on the world
I think people are understanding among
other things with the shake out of the
last year that nothing is a sure thing
and and and that you know a truck could
hit us tomorrow a recession can happen
tomorrow god knows what will happen
tomorrow so let's let's really try to
figure out what it is we love and gives
us satisfaction and go for that because
lord knows you know not nothing else is
for sure
even for all the craziness of the last
20 or 25 years and all the bad habits
that we developed over the last 15 20 25
years one of the great things that we've
seen is indeed a renaissance of the
amateur spirit in terms of the web the
creation of the web itself the creation
of all these digital tools so people can
make music and publish and and make
videos and make web applications and all
of these things that are have been
enabled is is is a revival of the
amateur spirit which is really central
to the American spirit let's let's make
it up as we go along let's let's let's
give full let's indulge our our
tinkering spirit we can do it that sort
of went out of fashion in a big and
profound way over the last hundred years
or so and the web and the digital
revolution generally has sort of enabled
anew so I think if we are one of the
things if we're able to write a story of
wow America turned the corner in the
early 21st century and and and and got
its mojo back I think one of the big
parts of that story will be that embrace
of the amateur spirit whether it's in
entrepreneurial senses and and the
entrepreneurial spirit is all about the
amateur spirit ultimately but the the
the the unwillingness to believe
absolutely that the experts know
anything worth knowing is also part of
the amateur spirit and certainly too
easy and too total and too complacent
belief that the experts knew what was
going on is certainly one of the things
that got us into trouble with all these
you know crazy financial derivatives
that nobody understood on Wall Street so
it's it's it's looking to oneself as a
citizen as as a potential entrepreneur
as an artist as whatever to to believe
in one's own ability to to
to know how to proceed and not simply
trust it all to the experts